مبادرات ودعوات ورداءات هي ما تتلقى
الخرطوم من المجتمع الدولي والاقليمي لوقف
الحرب بين الجيش السوداني وبين قوات الدعم
السريع وذلك لتحقيق هدنه يعقبها تفاوض لكن
بيانا للخارجيه السودانيه اكد اللا حوار
مع من سماهم البيان بالمتمردين وانه لا
خيار سوى واحد من اثنين اما الاستسلام او
القضاء على التمرد وهذا موقف جديد يبدو
مستدركا على ما اعلن من قبل بامكانيه عقد
لقاء بين ممثلين عن الجيش وعن الدعم
السريع في جبهه عاصمه جنوب السودان وفق
مبادره للايجاد تتضمن هدنه وحواره بين ان
مبادره الايجاد لم تحدد على ما يكون
التفاوض بين الجيش وبين قوات حميتي
المتمرده عليه بحسب وصفه لها
والدعوات الى وقف الحرب التي تساوي بين
الطرفين ربما تنزع الى رؤيه الصراع المسلح
وفق نموذج كلاسيكي في الصراع على السلطه
يقوم عاده بين الرئيس وبين نائبه وتتهم
هذه المقاربه بانها تغيب بجهل او بقصد
طبيعه الصراع وهي كما يراها الجيش
السوداني تمثل قفز على حقيقه ان الجيش
يخوض حربا في مواجهه قوه مسلحه تمردت عليه
بل انتقد فريق من السودانيين اسقاط
المجتمع الدولي بثلاثيته المكونه من الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
ومن رباعيته المكونه من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيه والامارات والسعوديه انتقض
اسقاطهم من الحساب طبيعه الدعم السريع
وهيكليه قيادته التي يمثلها الاخوان
انه الوضع العسكري الذي نشا ونمى وتضخم في
كنف العسكريه السودانيه وساهمت بعض القوى
السياسيه المدنيه في شرعنه وجوده بعد
الثوره حتى تحول من قوه عسكريه ذات مهام
خاصه الى نفوذ سياسي وعسكري ربما ارتات
هذه القوه السياسيه ان تجعل منه جسرا تمشي
عليه الى فردوسها الديمقراطي وقد كان
حملتي شديد الضيق بفكره الديمقراطيه حين
كانت الشوارع لا نشيد لها غير المطالبه
بالديمقراطيه والحكم المدني والديمقراطي
الديمقراطيه
كده هناك من السودانيين من يؤمن بان معركه
الجيش تبدو معركه تصحيح الاخطاء والخطايا
التي ورد موردها الاثم العسكر والسياسيون
جميعا بالتغاضي عن التشوهات الهيكليه
البائنه في جسد الدوله السودانيه وهو ما
انتهى بالثوره السودانيه الى واقع ينكر
فيه اخرها ما كان من شان اولها يوم كانت
الاحلام كبيره قبل ان تتقزم بذرائعيه
النفعيه جهلت ان تحجب نذر الحرب
وارهاصاتها حتى قامت بين يديها تفتح عيون
الجميع على ما تعاموا عن رؤيته وهو حقيقه
انه لا يوجد بلد في العالم بجيشين
وهذه الوضعيه غير السويه للدوله السودانيه
هي ما عكف المجتمع الدولي على التعاطي
معها لاصطناع ديموقراطيه يخلقها تخليقا من
نقائد الحاله السودانيه لتحقيق تحول
ديمقراطي يحمل عوامل فنائه في داخله وهي
خلاصه ما كان يشد عنها راي خبير بالشان
السوداني وبهذا المعنى فان الحرب تبدو
بتكاليفها الانسانيه الباهظه من موت
ودمائر ونزوح ولجوء هي الثمن الذي يدفعه
السودانيون رغم فداحته وعظمه لاستنقاذ
الدوله السودانيه من السقوط في يد قوه
عسكريه شادت امبراطوريتها الماليه وجيشها
واتباعها الاقتصاديين لا ينقصها الا حيازه
السلطه كامله فيكون الامر قسمه بينها وبين
رعاتها الاقليميين والدوليين يقول مؤيد
الجيش
لكم يبدو الثمن فادحا لتجنب تلاشي الدوله
السودانيه